dcns va me chercher mal est allé aux
valenciens se balade
[Musique]
je ne vais pas pleurer c'est déjà trop
trop belle
mais ses fils à papa qui brûlent pendant
10 ans et fait mieux reconnus comme il
est séparé je sais quel titre
alors maintenant on regarde regarde pas
dire ce que tu as mal aux yeux de ses
fans pour leurs auteurs
en effet et un truc à sa mémoire je vous
resterai aussi comme je ferme mes
cheveux là j'adore je me sens
[Musique]
ce à quoi chercher des visible tout ce à
quoi sa part temps tu connais un rôle
d'annie renseigne et moi on a travaillé
sur le sujet c'est sûr mais je joue bien
mais tu vas dans la rue je suis pas
[Musique]
super bien moi je choisisse ans
franchement je suis révolté
[Musique]
support
qui ne l'acceptent l'europe sur la
nature je pense que j'ai balancé tu
t'habitues tactical mintzer c'est vrai
j'avais vu le nouvel actros teneur en
vitamine c est vrai que ça de vue du
double des tracteurs ou 8 me sentirai
[Musique]
mc mc fait j'ai vu mon ex mais mon maxi
t'aimons blaquart actuel
[Musique]